we had a plan to pay for the wedding and
that plan did not go accordingly so we
ended up going into a bit of debt on top
of some pre-existing debt so now we're
just kind of looking for advice as newly
WS to what Happ start it off right and
get out of this what happened we took
about 32,000
well
$32,000 for a
wedding yeah there's a big red flag here
for me like something that's glaringly
like like glaring its red light and it's
the fact that early on you guys were hit
with a a fork in the road like do we
lower do we lower our budget and get
what we can afford or do we just say the
heck with it and you know put the pedal
to the metal and go into debt right